hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast a comprehensive toxicology
screening solution targeted to
individual needs I am Judy or our
collaborates and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinths this
presentation has been approved for
continuing education credits if you want
to obtain the credits please click on me
get your free secrets button located in
the lower left of your screen this will
take you to a page listing all of the
our speakers and presentations please
select the c/e button under the
presentation and follow the instructions
to claim your certificate we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker p wang PhD
dr. Peng Huang is the medical director
of clinical chemistry at houston
methodist hospital and associate
professor of pathology and laboratory
medicine at Weill Cornell Medical
College she is board certified in
clinical chemistry molecular diagnostics
and toxicological chemistry chemistry by
the American Board of clinical chemistry
for which she currently serves as vice
president and chair of the examination
committee dr. Wong is a fellow of the
national academy of clinical
biochemistry she currently serves or has
served on the boards of nakka a acc lv
DD division and TDM and toxicology
division dr. Wong has received many
honors and awards including the career
cornerstone award
NAC be distinguished abstract award and
the aacc outstanding research award just
published over 60 peer-reviewed papers
abstracts and book chapters dr. Wong has
over ten years of experience directing
and managing high complexity CLIA
clinical laboratories and is an expert
in clear regulations laboratory
management to drive clinical efficiency
quality and outcome clinical assay
development optimization and execution
in a highly regulated environment dr.
Wong's current research interests focus
on translating novel research and
startup findings into clinical
diagnostic tools she is principal
investigator of two nih grants and
actively collaborates with major
diagnostic companies as well as startup
ventures to develop next-generation
diagnostic tools i will now turn it over
to dr. Wang for her presentation
thank you very much Judy for the nice
introduction so today I'm going to talk
about a comprehensive toxicology
screening solution targeted to
individual needs so first of all a
little bit overview what I will be
talking about today I will touch upon a
little bit on the background of clinical
toxicology screening and talk about the
current approaches we use in clinical
toxicology screening and then I will
lead that to limitations of the current
approach and then to illustrate that
better I will talk about two different
cases which are real case is happening
in our institution and then give you the
flavor of what i mean by limitations of
the current approaches and then after
that we want to address the limitations
and introduce our new solution for this
toxicology screening approach so to do
that we engage our clinical providers we
push down the survey to the clinical
providers here in the institution so I
will talk a little bit about about the
survey where the survey contains and
then we'll review the results of the
survey briefly and then after that I
will go a little bit in depth into the
analytical approach we use to address
the companies and what we have developed
as the final solution to the toxicology
screening approach here so first of all
a little bit background and clinical
toxicology screening so most of us who
are in the field of clinical toxicology
probably know that the urine drugs of
abuse testing is probably the most
frequently used a tour in clinical
toxicology screening most of the
hospital labs as well as reference labs
will get a lot of others for the urine
tracks of abuse many of them may come
from the Arth example the emergency room
and some of them may come from other
places so depending on where you are
which lab yuying and which platform you
use means urine drugs and abuse testing
typically contain about seven to nine
drugs
and they're usually immunoassays to
adapt to the needs of quick turnaround
time and they are usually not
multiplexed so you have to run different
assays to get answers for different
drugs in order to report them to your
honoring physicians with the exception
that sometimes point-of-care devices can
give you a cartridge with several
different drugs can be incorporated on
the same cartridge and you may be able
to get answers from the same cartridge
so again depending on the platform and
when your use this may contain
phencyclidine benzodiazepines cocaine
and fan Ming's THC opiates barbiturates
tressa antidepressants as well as
methadone and sometimes methylone
metabolites so the results are usually
presumptive positive so as a matter of
fact per cap regulation for example if
you look at the cab checklist there's a
requirement that you have to report
these results as presumptive positive
and if the clinicians want a
confirmatory results then usually they
have to send that out I conformation
which are typically done by mass
spectrometry not every liable to have
mass spectrometry so traditionally this
would be assembled tests in most
Hospital labs and the tour on time
depending on the geographic location and
the reference lab you use typically is
about week so any kind of and clinical
intervention that will need quick
turnaround time and quick results we not
not be able to be a mystery within that
time frame so I kind of touched a little
bit already on the limitations of the
current clinical toxicology screening
approaches but then here's a slide kind
of summarizing what I just talked about
and it will be more so the limitations
first of all this is a limited menu of
729 drugs and depending on vendor and
platform and only covers what were
historically considered to be frequently
abused drugs so the menu has not changed
for many years historically we know
these with
that are prone to be abused a lot by the
potentially the patient population
however as we know in the clinical
toxicology and medical toxicology area
the providers know that we have new
designer drugs appearing out almost
every day now so with a menu Annette has
not changed for many years the question
remains whether this is still sufficient
to cover the current medical worker no
toxicology knees I think if you talk to
any medical talk on the toxicologist
they will tell you the answer is no the
drugs the drugs of abuse testing many we
use now is not sufficient to cover many
clinical knees in today's word and then
the second limitation is the low
sensitivity for some of the compounds
and tablets so one of the example would
be benzos and I will be giving you some
case examples as was talk a little bit
further about a literature search and
things behind the benzo example and then
the third limitation is low specificity
or cross reactivity so the low
sensitivity is caused by limited
reactivity of the assay with me tablets
and sometimes some compounds in a family
of drugs or medications and the cross
reactively to unwanted compounds or
things that are not included in the
abused list cause issues for low
specificity so these are the major
current limitations that these screening
approaches we use today so to give you a
little bit flavor here here is a case
number one which is a real case
happening now institution so here's a
patient who was admitted for inpatient
psychiatric treatment and he was
prescribed to lorazepam with a brand
name at event at two milligrams per tid
for his medical condition and the urine
drug screen or UDS has been performed
repeatedly over the past year at our
institution to rule out drugs of abuse
and also to monitor compliance with
therapy since March 2014 the urine drug
screen has been repeatedly negative for
benzodiazepines and one note here is
that all the prior UDS died in the same
institution on same patient and always
being positive for benzodiazepine but
the patient insist that he has continued
to take his medication as prescribed so
while the patient was admitted for he is
inpatient psychiatric treatment to
ensure that he was taking his medication
the clinical pharmacist actually
documented the demonstration and
observed administration of lorazepam to
the patient however when they continue
to send the UDS to our lab for urine
drugs of abuse testing the pencil result
continues to be negative for this
particular and light so the clinical
pharmacist and a point for the inpatient
psychiatry floor was calling us for an
explanation and asking whether he should
trust the patient and the ward lab
result so this is a typical dilemma that
all providers may face and then that may
be presented to us as laboratory ins so
in the table below the on the bottom of
the slide here you can see here are as
the results for benzodiazepines for this
for this patient in question so we use
Roche assays immunoassays for depends oh
drugs of abuse screening and repeatedly
as I mentioned before the pencil result
has been negative so to troubleshoot
this to investigators case we send the
patient sample to another site which is
a community a hospital in our health
system who use trailers testing platform
for drugs of abuse screening so the
result came back as positive for
benzodiazepine and we also send out the
same sample to a send out reference lab
for GC mass back confirmation so again
the result came back as reporting a high
concentration of lorazepam glucuronide
so in this is typical case illustrating
the limitations of our urine drug abuse
screening today
so a poly investigation we noted we as a
lab switched from triage SI to the Roche
Kim's essay for UDS in 2014 so the Kim's
as they stand for kinetic interaction of
microparticles in solution this was in a
say on Roche on mission platform and
then we noted that the Roche essay has a
very low cross reactivity for lorazepam
glucuronide so if you know get a package
insert it is knowing that the cross were
activity for lorazepam kokoro night
which is a major metabolite lorazepam is
only one point one percent so let's say
if you use a 300 milligrams per meal as
a cuddle for benzo tell thespian for
example using a typical compound in the
men's Oh class which is north as Pam and
300 milligrams per meal as a cut off
then you have to have higher than to
20,000 nanograms per mil of lorazepam
glucuronide for the assay to turn off a
positive result and that typically is
not achieved in a urine sample from any
kind of patient who is either taking a
prescription drug or it was abusing this
particular compound on air handlers Pam
is rapidly conjugated with glucuronic
acid which will accumulate in plasma and
finally accumulate in the urine
seventy-five percent of the dose
eliminated in the urine would be in a
form of lorazepam glucuronide and only
fourteen percent would be as conjugates
of other minor metabolites negligible
amounts of iron change the drugs will be
found in the urine so as a matter of
fact if the assay was designed to target
detection of lorazepam then this is not
very meaningful for your interactive
abuse winning because you will find
better lethal lorazepam Kankuro night in
the patient's urine and this was not the
only compound that had a very low cross
reactivity with the particular
immunoassay so another example would be
for example temazepam karana which is
another metabolite for the benzyl group
of compounds so the cross-reactivity to
that is the lower at
seven percent so you have to have
300,000 diagrams for me equivalence of
Miss metab light for the essay to turn
out a positive result which basically
was saying that you will never be able
to see a positive result for a patient
who was taking this medication and this
was not how our observation was not only
finding of course in the literature so
if you knew King literature there are
many different reports and articles that
have reported similar observations so I
just give you my example here this was a
paper published in 2014 on pain
physician so in the table here they
actually compared the false negative
rates of three different amino acids for
urine drugs of abuse screening Sony's
included Kim's as a dissidia as a NHS
CDI assay and then the listed several
compounds in the class of
benzodiazepines upon among them would be
lorazepam Quran and for example and then
they compare the false negative rates
and the range and the mean concentration
of the particular benzyl daz bein in
these immunoassays so as you can see
this is not a particular problem
isolated just to one particular vendor
or even as a it's a universal problem
common for many different assays and
many different vendors and this may not
only be limited to one compound either
it can affect many different compounds
and actually not limited to only
benzodiazepines as well so to illustrate
more point on limitations of clinical
toxicology screening approaches we have
a second case here so in case number two
is a patient with reporting medications
admitting for opiate detox so below I
listed the reporting medications on a
medical record so he was taking xanax
were away the generic name alprazolam at
20 milligrams daily and
here's what's reporting on one placing
his medical record well here is the
issue coming if you are relying on
documentation for medical record because
depending on where you nuclear medical
records actually you may find
conflicting documentation for example
another note in the same patients
electronic electronic medical record
says that he was taking various spends
of Jasmine's not just alprazolam so the
question comes exactly what he was
taking and even the documented
medication history can be a little bit
confusing and reliable at times and then
of course because he was a mean for
opiate detox he was prescribed oxycodone
at 200 milligrams per per day for this
treatment purpose but again another note
in the same medical record says that he
was using multiple opiates and not
oxycodone specifically so again and this
is a conflicting point and really you
are trying to rely on lab results to
tell whether exactly what the patient
was taking and then he report
self-report also cannabis use and then
there is also gamma panting on the
medication list and quality and yellow
in the table you could see the drugs of
abuse testing result so on the right
side you can see here is the Roche
testing result which is what we use
again as even a safe or the urine tracks
of abuse screening so as consistent to
his reporting medications use you can
see benzyl being positive consistent
with he is either xanax use were
multiple different benzodiazepine use
and then everything else was negative
besides the THC which which was also
consistent with reporting medication use
however I expected finding here is the
oxycodone so oxycodone result turn out
to be negative and upon repeating of the
same sample in CL came out as negative
so here's the question is the patient
really taking his medication oxycodone
as part of his opiate detox program
agreement so from the lab
the answer seems to be yes adjust to the
answers and I'm sorry the answer seems
to be no so but just really make sure
and we want to make sure there is no
analytical false negatives here we want
to confirm the test result but here the
question comes if we send out to our
sister Hospital who was using a trailers
platform they actually don't have
oxycodone no test manual here on the
triage platform so in this case this is
a moot point to actually send to a
neighboring institution with a triage
platform because the test Emmanuel
limitation on that particular platform
so this again case illustrates how much
importance the lab result plays in your
patient management of medical toxicology
as well as the limitations we have in
today's tours so realizing these kind of
limitations then as a clinical
laboratory and our next step is to try
to come up with a new solution to help
our clinical providers so to achieve
that we first need to take a look and
who was honoring the UDS more or most
and we would like to be able to address
the unease sorry that's my office light
go out make sure it's on so to do this
we did a internal audit looking at my
institutions UDS ordering pattern so on
the graph here you can see the peak the
highest peak here of course came from
yard so the emergency room was ordering
a lots of means your interactive views
and then there are also smaller Peaks
distribute across the hospital so needs
include medical intensive care units and
their residence teaching services
psychiatric units and neurology floor
and then the internal medicine
hepatology units for example and then
our next step is to assign a clinical
user survey and then send a survey out
to these most frequent users of our UDS
tests so we send them to providers in ED
oncology neurology Creek
air pulmonary internal medicine critical
care gastroenterology hepatology and
transplant so in this survey we
basically posed the three basic
questions here what was the reason for
you to order the UDS result testing and
then what are on time requirement we
have for your testing ease and then
let's say if we propose a more
comprehensive toxicology testing
solution with higher sensitivity
specificity and with a trade-off now
they may come up come back to you with a
slightly longer around time and this
time frame would be two to three days
would you the interest you using this
new service when you test so I put in
the table below the some of the
responses from the providers so as you
can see the reasons for altering varies
between different providers and I will
reveal that and summarize mat in next
slide for you but to run time needed
most of them say of course as quickly as
you can but typically they would be
minimal to a two to three hours two to
three days at a long time for this more
accurate test results and all of them
express knees in using this new test or
new solution we propose to the to them
so to summarize a little bit on the
clinical goals these providers were
trying to achieve here so the first
clinical go would be emerging toxicity
assessment and that will be the foremost
to go for example in ER environment and
then there's also a drug overdose
assessment patient behavior risk
stratification medication compliance
monitoring and then finally regulatory
compliance for downstream clinical
interventions for example in our
transplant service units so as you can
see here the criminal goals of these
individuals really vary a lot and then
if you ask the question whether our
current clinical toxicology is going to
work and can meet these individual needs
then the answer is no so our solution is
try to develop something that we
be able to meet with which we will be
able to meet individual needs of the
clinical providers so as a clinical
laboratory and our analytical go here or
have to reflect what the conoco go he is
so our analytical goal is to set up a
comprehensive toxicology screening
program to meet individual clinical
needs so here is what we have in mind
and will be proposed to to develop the
comprehensive toxicology solution in
turn into individual needs so we divided
the providers into two different
categories on the right side you can see
here is Ed and they all prime purpose is
to assess the toxicity in emerging
environment for the patients who come
through their doors so for this purpose
turon time is very important and
typically the immunoassay even though
there are many limitations they may have
with the quick to run time may still be
the current best current solution for
the ED purpose and of course as needed
we can always reflects the email assets
to a more comprehensive testing for the
ED providers as well and now on the left
side you can see for many other clinical
providers such as oncology neurology
critical care transform and internal
medicine their knees mostly focus on
overdose assessment behavior risk
stratification and compliance monitoring
and phenom the limitation of the current
immunoassays are very obvious so we
propose to do a swinging approach using
else intellimouse back SI to come a
cover many drugs and now metabolites in
one run and therefore providing our
results to these clinical providers to
meet their knees so in order to develop
this analytical solution here are the
tours and the approaches we took so
basically we want to develop else
eternal mass spec method and that can
simultaneously quantitate some of the
eight drugs and metabolites in urine at
the same time and we want to have a very
simple sample preparation procedure the
goal is you mean
sample preparation and with a go final
go to shorten to run time as much as we
need so we used a simple unit and should
approach rather than a complicated
extraction approach and the other
approach we adopted was to incorporate
the direct glucuronide conjugates
quantitation into method so there are
two different ways you can go here for
working to piranha conjugates one way is
to undergo hydrolysis and then quantify
the glucuronide as part of the parent
compound in the end your method so if
you look in the literature there are
different methods using either acid
hydrolysis and or enzymatic hydrolysis
however the issue here is not whether
which approach you use depending on
which approach used the efficiency of
hydrolysis varies from one method to the
other and may vary from one compound to
another as well so it's hard to optimize
the hydrolysis efficiency for all the
compounds especially when you have a
large menu here so all approaches to go
the other way and just incorporate the
quantitation of Google own eyes directly
as much as we can into the menu itself
and this may take a little bit more
effort in the beginning for methyl
development that you will really pay off
in the end as I will try to show you in
a few slides later in our methyl
comparison studies and then because
there is such a broad menu we separated
them into a positive ionization method
and the negative ionization method to
maximize the ionization efficiency for
each of the compound menu so the
advantage here is that we can use the
same column in the same mobile phase for
the two different methods which is to
simply another injection switch the
negative organization after first run is
done and then do another injection and
then the mass spec will use was the ABC
x55 100 q trap mass spectrometer and
which was tagged to a shimadzu you h
see instrument the column were used was
a biphenyl column and with gradient
elution comprising point one person
formic acid water being the mobile phase
a and point one percent of formic acid
in methanol being mobile phase B so if
you want to see more about technical
details then I recommend you refer to
our published article in journal of a
medical toxicology for more technical
details so here is our compound list I
know this is a pretty small print and
it's a long list so I won't belabor and
go through every item on this compound
list but it suffice to say that takes us
a lot of effort to try to identify the
precursor as well as the dollar amounts
for each of these compounds and then we
also optimized each of the DP the
clustering potential and collision
energy as well as the other parameters
for each of these compound so continue
along next slide is a continuation of
the compound list so I do want to
mention one of the compounds on our menu
which was nor propoxyphene so and this
was a particular challenging in life for
us no propoxyphene has been reported in
literature to be unstable and it may
degrade two different degradation
products that major ones being MPD and
this is a psycho eyes psycho psycho
lized metabolite for nor propoxyphene
and this conversion can be ongoing
constantly so this can happen you a
patient sample your patient urine sample
and they also happen you are analyzed in
your in your calibrators as well as your
qcs so this is a particular challenge
challenge because how do you know
exactly you are accurately quantify do
not propoxyphene concentration your
patient sample you can note also the m20
a show of these two compounds are quite
different as well so in our method what
the solution we came up to address miss
challenged was to quantify no
propoxyphene and MPD separately and then
we convert the NPV concentration
mathematically back
to know propulsive and some together the
total concentration so basically the
equation we use was to quantify the peak
area of MPD and the normalized mat with
the mass m to Z ratio between the two
compound and then sum that up with the
nor propoxyphene concentration will peak
area we observed and then normalize that
to the internal standard pink area so in
this approach was able to generate a
linear calibration curves for us for no
purpose event and then when we did
spiking analysis and experimentation we
found out we can get very accurate and
precise validation results from this
approach which indicate this is a valid
method for the solving the challenge of
new propoxyphene and then here is the
internal standard pairing a table here
and again this is a long list so I won't
go through each of them but as much as
we can we try to find a deuterated
standards for each of the compound and
this may not be commercially available
for each compound so we try to match the
compound with a chemical structure
similar compound for internal standard
and here the slide shows the
chromatograms we generated for on the
Left would be the positive ionization
method and on the right would be the
negative ionization method as you can
see here we have definitely more
compounds and metabolites in the
positive ionization method and much
smaller and therefore a much shorter run
time for our negative ionization method
and here's a table summarizing the SI
validation Fighting's again this is
pretty small apologize for the small
print but basically for each of the
compound we have addressed the
calibration linear coefficient C and
then we have selected the cutoff for us
to call either illness was positive and
negative and typically the cuddle
concentration would be taken from most
of the mass back column concentration
used for confirmation and then a well
rubber we
can find such a color of concentration
then we will reflect that from a
medically decision limit standpoint and
then we also have our linear range
mapped out for each of these lower limit
of detection lower limit of quantitation
and then sample stability at four degree
we typically store our samples more than
a week so we looked at at least the
sample stability for at least a week and
determining most of them would be pretty
stable over in a time course and then we
also have our other perimeters mapped
out for the assay validation as well so
as a summary here we have two levels of
QC we have a low level QC which was set
at fifty percent of the cutoff and we
have a high level QC which was at three
times of the Kellogg concentration and
the inter and intra as high precision
add to queue sea levels we had with less
than y equal to ten percent for most of
the analytes the recovery was generally
pretty good between 80 to 100 percent
for most of the analytes except for some
of the following listing slides here so
typically you can see some of them were
around sixty percent and some of the
nowhere as high as 150 percent so we
hypothesized that that this was caused
because these compounds did not have
available to three internal standards so
they had to be matched to another or
chemically similar compound for the
quantitation and that may cause some
some accuracy issues in the quantitation
and of course we want to confirm or test
DPT proficiency testing performance of
our method so here is a cab d npm
proficiency testing specimens comprising
two different samples and we run them
through as a nuclear test performance so
one of the columns here you can see our
else eternal mass spec method results
and then if you compare to the
acceptable range and the mean
quantitation mean concentration of all
the quantitation methods that you can
see that our accuracy is pretty high
Rick at looking at around one hundred
percent for most of the compounds very
close to me of the different methods so
this indicated our methods was would
perform successfully in a proficiency
testing survey and then we also did
method comparison so to do this we
randomly selected 20 different patient
urine samples and then we tested them
in-house here both using our immune acid
which is our current clinical toxicology
screening tour and they will also run
them on our else eternal mass spec which
is our new method and will also split
the samples and then send them to a
reference lab who is using a tough high
resolution for screening for some of the
analytes and the immunoassay for other
analytes and then it is positive then
the reference lab the reflects that to a
LC ton of mass spec sa were sometimes
the GC mass spec has day so we compared
our testing results with the reference
lab test results in most cases the
correlation was pretty good with the
exception of a few cases which I would
like to discuss a little bit further so
the first category of method comparison
results I'd like to acquire oil
attention to is this case here so vp3 is
I want to be urine samples we send out
and also do the internal correlation in
our email SI it was turned out as
positive for EM feminine for the regime
as we use and now the mass spec sa-weet
testing house here actually there was
lorazepam will arrive at relatively low
concentration 97 and then runs per mil
and then when we slim add to the
reference lab the reference lab came out
as negative for all of the compounds on
our menu and then therefore no mass spec
assay for confirmation was performed so
to address the difference here we looked
at a clinical medical record in this
patient this
this was from a patient from the
emergency room who in complained of
severe insomnia lasting for a few days
so even though we did not have a
comprehensive list of all the
medications the patient was taking while
he was outside the hospital but it could
be reasonable to hypothesize that
patient could have taken a sedative or
sleep-inducing drug for his insomnia so
for example or as Pam would be such a
sedative compound for the patient to use
or travel home for sleep inducing drug
and then if you look in the literature
that you thought you can find out tresno
metabolite mcpp was reported to have
cross reactivity with Roche and family
SI so to verify this we spiked to some
mcpp into our blank urine samples and
then testing our in-house Roche SI and
we do find that though the essay
generated some false positive and family
results from mcpp as long as the
compartment the concentration was ten
micrograms per meal will be higher than
that so in this case I think the n
family result from women si was a false
positive potentially from the trousseau
metabolites and their lorazepam of
course given the poor reactivity of
lorazepam glucuronide in our essay we
didn't expect immunoassay was able to
detect but our LC mass spec has a wish
was well new method was able to catch
this at relatively low concentration and
we suspect because the amino acid was he
probably used in reference lab and this
was a potentially why lorazepam was also
not called in the reference lab as a so
this kind of illustrates a advantage of
using the LZ t animas pakka makka say as
a up from screening tour in which you
can actually decrease and avoid some of
the false positives and then catch some
of the false negatives as well another
case here is a urine that was positive
for benzodiazepine on our MSA and also
tricycle
antidepressants when we when we test the
sample on else autonomous back a mass
spec assay the tramadol and tremolo
metabolites showed up at a pretty high
concentration and North Antonio also was
detected a relatively low concentration
so this was basically very similar to
what was reflecting back from all sent
out reference lab results which was also
positive for tramadol and tremolo me
tablet so I think this okay in this case
the benzo and TCA would be false
positive results on our MSA because none
of the LC mass spec house I was able to
detect it and us again illustrates the
potential to generate false positives
using current email SI technology and
then the third classes of comparison
cases here comprised of two different
cases so what the first case was
positive on benzo and opiates on our
immunoassay and then on the lcms back a
say we can say we can see many different
kind of opiates were positive and then
there are also tramadol and then there
are also benzodiazepines working them
metabolites and amino clonazepam as well
so this was consistent with our amino
acid results and then we look at the
reference lab results then we see the
number of drugs a detective was a little
bit smaller we see Opia some of the
opiates we see some of the tremolo but
we didn't really see the benzodiazepines
being detected in the reference lab
result and similarly the second case was
possible publisher rates which was
consistent with the LCMS packinghouse
here but none of these was detected on
the reference lab swinging essay and
therefore no confirmation was performed
so in this case our in-house muna sa was
consistent with the LC turn a mass spec
result we have in-house and the shorter
list of detected compounds may be caught
in the reference lab we be caused by the
limited
reactivity of they are amino acids or
the high resolution 12 a say in the
screening approach and then here's
another class of comparison results so
for all three cases in this class we
detected various different compounds and
when we tested them on RLC mass spec
assay that you can see most of these
compounds detected organic or own eyes
including okeus and then in a few cases
other a compound other glucuronide
compounds as well so and then this was
ad pretty high concentration actually
but then if you refer compare that to
the reference lab send out test results
then you see they identified actually a
much shorter list so this comparison
indicate the advantage of directly
incorporating you can colonize into the
swinging methods this can potentially
enhanced sensitivity and provide more
accuracy and sensitivity in the
compounds you can detect any up from
swinging approach so to summarize a
little bit of the analytical lessons we
have gone through in the previous lies
in our method developed process we
adopted a simple de nuit and shoot
method and we directly quantify
liberalizing on methods and we separated
positive negative on elec yes I methods
to maximize the ionization what also
found out at the THC carboxylic acid and
is gonna corona compounds tend to stick
to container surfaces and this may
include both glass and plastic surfaces
and this can cause accuracy and
reproducibility issues for some of the
validation as well as patient testing so
our solution to address this was to
prepare the calibrators and kissies in
fifty percent of methanol and this was
able to mitigate this problem however
the same issue preventing tunisian for
these analyzed for even patient urine
testing because then the accuracy of
natty notion may become a problematic so
indecision something that I wanted to
mention here in case you do
similar troubleshooting a method
development in your lab and then we
mentioned about no propoxyphene to MPD
quantitation challenge so our solution
again is to emily's both of these and
then summing them up and then convert
them into a normalizing in terms of the
mass with Z ratio so again this manual
calculation was successful in generating
linear calibration curves accurate and
precise validation results and then we
talked about false positive and famines
on Roche essays with cross reactivity to
mcpp the trazodone metabolites and we'll
also talk in depth about false negative
benzodiazepines on the immunoassays with
logan colonize cross reactivity and then
when we talked about directly detecting
and quantifying with your own eyes and
the advantage of news is that we can
enhance sensitivity and avoid false
negatives and another advantage which I
did not mention was actually we can help
identify the down with these specimens
because if the patient was meaning
either of blank urine spiked with parent
compound or some other matrices other
than urine for testing then we would
know this up front because no
glucuronide would be would be seen on
RLC mass spec method and this is a
particular way to help identify
adulterated specimens so once we have
the analytical method in place we went
to had to assess our clinical engagement
so again based on honoring physician
ease we propose we watch we urge the
urine drug screen orders to two
different methods here they will be
trailers to immunoassays if they are
from Ed for emergent toxicity assessment
or for other providers well the tehran
time is a little bit can be a little bit
longer then we'll all jurors them to
directly to the mass spectrometry-based
screening and the quantitation for their
own individual needs and after that is
very important that we provide a
comprehensive report for every sample we
test to report to the clinician and then
analyze and then explain to the
clinician
finding was so other than just reporting
positive integrity of what the
concentration is we know that the
metabolism pathway and the menu of the
method is very comprehensive and may be
hard for the clinician to comprehend so
here is what we provide interpretation
divided our finding into either a
consistent with reporting medication
needs medication use were inconsistent
with medication use and then under each
header we report the specific compound
detected and then the concentration
detected as well so this will help with
the clinicians interpretation and then
as needed we can also provide phone
consultation as well so here's the graph
summarizing the final solution we have
basically adapted on the previous slide
I have shown here and this is a
comprehensive toxicology solution
targeted to different individual needs
of our providers so depending on their
location what our knees we triage them
to different testing either lcms back or
the immunoassays and amino acids can be
reflexed to the awesome aspect if
clinically needed and then by using this
approach we believe we add value by
covering more drug in our menu so let us
include 78 drugs and now metabolites and
we also add value by increased our
sensitivity and specificity of the
testing as I mentioned we can help
identify jority specimens and then most
importantly I think the interpretation
and consultation is very important to
our clinicians to help them better
understand the test results so to circle
back to the first two cases and that I
mentioned to you in the beginning of the
presentation so remember a case one was
the patient admitted form a psychiatric
treatment and had repeatedly false
negative benzoic as being testing so in
into a test when this case would
actually be in our news toxicology
solution we test the patient's urine on
our Alice autonomous back
si so remember the patient was reporting
medication used including lorazepam and
garba panting and as expected we were
able to see both on these compounds for
lorazepam mostly as the metabolite Louis
kombucha row night and pretty high
concentration in a patient's urine so
this cooperates the patient's medical
use of lorazepam and give our clinical
pharmacist more assurance in our testing
results in case two was a patient with
report a long list of reporting
medications and was admitted to opiate
detox program and remember we were
saying that even as the results were the
report Lee negative for oxycodone so we
then tested the patience on our LCMS
back a say-so in this assay we can see
all problem was positive which was
consistent with the medication reporting
news and then there was also oxazepam
glucuronide at relatively low
concentration so this cooperates the
documentation that the patient was
actually using multiple different
benzodiazepines other than just the
xenex and then benzyl acne was positive
consistent with the report you use as
well garber panting was consistent with
medication and then I'm sorry THC
glucuronide was consistent with report
use but wenzel acne was kind of
unexpected fighting because that was not
on patients reported medication use but
from the awesome ass back si we can
again see there was no oxycodone or any
of the metabolites detected so this
gives our clinician more assurance
indeed the patient was not taking the
prescribed oxycodone and therefore gives
them or two or more confidence in
confronting the patient in the opioid
detox program so to summarize here we
have shown shown that the traditional
UDS cannot meet the various individual
needs of the clinical providers and here
we have set up a comprehensive
toxicology screening solution to utilize
triple quadruple else
to annemasse back to include screening
and quantitation of 78 drugs and
metabolites and this approach has an
advantage over simple using email as a
full screening or a high-resolution mass
spec for screening which hopefully have
convinced you in now in our method
comparison examples and the clinically
the solution as value to providers by
providing a more comprehensive manual
coverage potential detection of
adulterated specimens increasing
sensitivity and specificity and results
interpretation and consultation and all
of these can strengthen the role of
laboratory ins in proactively
contributing to the patient care so with
that I thank you for your attention and
I'd like to entertain any questions you
may have thank you dr. juan for that
important of presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session i'd like to remind our audience
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can and
first question is do you see positive
propoxyphene samples I understand that
it has not been available in the US for
several years so yeah the answer is we
do see very few propoxyphene positive
samples but again that depends on
probably the geographic area in our
location we see really the propulsive
and positive samples but definitely
wanted to from time to time still
could you talk more about what is
special for the seven drugs that were
chosen to develop for toxicology tests
by roche and other vendors in tradition
sure so from my understanding the seven
drugs or sometimes depending on the
platform of users maybe you know eight
or nine different drugs may be chosen by
different vendors because historically
they have been shown to have high
potential abuse use and then from
epidemiology studies it has been shown
that there are a lot of abuse for in
this particular compound as well but
again the menu has not been changed for
many years and then gradually though has
been addition to the menu as well for
example methadone metabolites which is
not to be available on these clinical
toxicology screening gradually became
available and has been incorporated on
to some of the testing platforms and the
same thing will be six men which is a
metab life or heroin use for example but
there again with the ever-changing
landscape of control toxicology and
medical toxicology the you know the
manual change still can catch up with
the current landscape changing real
practice so this is still a significant
problem now the menu is not able to
cover the current knees clinically
how do you determine the turnaround time
and can you decrease it further to meet
the physicians ideal request so yeah
that is a very interesting question so
from the clinician standpoint they'll
request is usually to have a test result
turn back to them as fast as possible
ideally minutes now be great but then I
think from the maroons perspective we
not only want to turn out the term on
time very rapidly but also want to make
sure the results we turn back to them is
valid is accurate and specific and
that's why in particular situations like
this you have to balance the two
different needs so in the context of LC
tournaments backpack mass spec testing
you you can it's very challenging for
you to achieve a Toronto as fast as you
are screening i would say probably it's
not possible ever because you know again
even with a minimum sample preparation
you still have to undergo the the
analysis process which is typically much
longer than typical immunoassay and this
is not remember a automating high
throughput platform this is a pretty
menu a say so i think when a two-day is
typically turn on time this is probably
already a very good tour on time for
clinicians so i don't think we can ever
achieve like 45 minutes for a long time
to give them the results have been
stretching i think the article goes here
what about lithium toxicity screening
how long would it take for the positions
to be informed in order to prescribe the
right dose of the medication
so lithium is actually not including any
of the either immuno the clinical
toxicology screening or the mass spec
but it is available as a standalone a
different email a say so you can monitor
the lithium is part of the therapeutic
drug monitoring testing you offer in a
clinical lab and that typically will
give the clinicians a rapid to run time
and give them an idea how to titrate our
doses sorry let me turn on the office
lights here what are the steps involved
in sample prep hydrolysis and what does
each step accomplish okay let me let me
repeat that question what are the steps
involved in sample prep hydrolysis and
what does each step accomplish sure so
the basic steps for sample preparation
for a for example a clinical toxicology
mass spec testing would be typically to
first to precipitate out the protein in
the urine matrix and then secondly to
either use acid or enzyme to hydrolyze
the equal quran I'd conjugates from
different metabolites so the goal is to
generate the lagoon colonize which is a
typical moiety in the metabolites of
different compounds and then quantify
these compounds together as they are
parent parent drug in the compound so
that's the goal is to achieve the
quantitation as a single compound but as
I mentioned before this may not be very
efficient for all the compounds and
hydrolysis efficiency really vary from
one method to the other and from one
compound to another so to us the best
approach was just to avoid that
variability and directly detect the you
can occur on I compounds in our method
so I hope that makes sense
we have time for one last question how
is the lower limit of detection decided
so the lower limit of detection was
decided usually by running a blank urine
sample in this case on our else
autonomous back sa and then quantified
the potential mean and standard
deviation from that blank urine sample
and then the lower limit of detection
detection usually is determined by ming
of that blank sample plus free standard
deviation so this indicates that for
blank sample to come through here is
your lower limit of detection to say
that if it's non blank sample this is a
low limit I can detect but again are
usually that's not the same as a lower
limit of quantitation so low limit of
quantitation which is another term is
usually determined by where the assay
can attain about twenty percent cv
coefficient of variation and then we
typically use the lower limit of
quantitation as the lower end of our
reporting and calibration curve all
right I think that's all for my answer I
would like to once again thank dr. Wong
for her presentation to have any final
comments dr. Wong
well at this point I just want to thank
everybody who have login to view the
presentation and I hope you take home
something useful from the presentation
and I would like to thank Allah Bruce
for organizing this event so that I am
able to share my experience with the
audience and if you have any questions
in the future just feel free to contact
me by email or by phone you should be
able to find my contact information
methodist website so thank you again for
your attention thank you dr. Juan this
presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits if you
want to obtain the credits please click
on the get your free CEO credits button
located in the lower left of your screen
this will take you to a page listing all
of our speakers and presentations please
click please select the c/e button under
the presentation and follow the
instructions to claim your certificate
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May eleventh
2016 you'll receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye